the lure of online gambling has made it
all so easy to spend and fast
David Bradford's family had no idea he'd
racked up half a million pounds worth of
debt until they got the call that he was
on his way to prison I use of every
source of funding for my gambling
addiction I like him at the time to be
in an Amster wheel way he just couldn't
get off but you were pedaling and
pedaling faster and faster and just
getting something - more and more debt
what doesn't help according to a
committee of MPs is the government and
gambling Commission's unacceptably weak
understanding of the impact betting can
have describing the regulator as
toothless we found a regulator that is
too slow to act it's too weak to you
identified robust action it doesn't have
any targets to reduce the levels of
problem gambling which are at three
hundred ninety five thousand people in
the UK are problem gamblers and
individuals can't get proper address the
committee's report has called for a
radical overhaul of the regulator it
wants a league table of operators naming
and shaming poor performers an urgent
review of the gambling Act setting out a
timetable for that within three months
improved collection of data to better
understand gambling problems and then
respond and an urgent investigation into
the impact of fixed odds betting legally
accessible to 16 and 17-year olds part
of the issue is that the gambling
industry is changing so fast there's no
need to go to the bookies to bet instead
it's all available on a screen with new
games emerging all the time a
spokesperson for the Department for
Culture Media and Sport said it was
committed to protecting people from
gambling related risks while the
regulator said it was determined to
deliver faster progress adding over the
past two years we have strengthened
player protection measures tightened the
regulation of the online sector
introduced strict age and ID
verification checks brought in a ban on
gambling with credit cards
and being tougher through our
enforcement activity David spent eight
months in prison since then he and his
son have set up the safer online
gambling group to increase awareness of
the risks they know firsthand just how
damaging it can be Emma virtually Sky
News